To finish off the section on exponent methods. let's look at an interest
problem. let's say that Grant puts $1000 in an account that receives 3% interest
per year compounded yearly. How long is it going to take for him to have $1250
in the account? Well, let's remember that equation that we used for calculating
compound interest before. It was A equals P times 1 plus r over n to the nt.
Here A is equal to the money in the account. P is equal to the principal, the
amount initially invested. R is the interest rate per year written as a
decimal. N is the number of times interest is compounded each year. And t is
equal to the number of years that have passed. So, what we really need to come
up with right now is an equation for A after t years, of course, making it fit
this situation. Please write that in here.